las evacuaciones se prolongaron mientras
la lava del volcán cumbre vieja
continuaba su camino de devastación
miles de residentes en la palma en las
islas canarias españolas se han visto
obligados a huir desde la erupción del
domingo
nos dijeron que saliéramos de nuestra
casa porque había una posible erupción
así que para asegurarnos nos pidieron
que nos fuéramos al menos por un tiempo
con una velocidad media de 700 metros
por hora y con cerca de 1000 grados de
temperatura crece la preocupación por el
daño que la lava podría dejar a su paso
cientos de casas han sido destruidas
para muchos residentes no está claro
cuándo podrán regresar
creo que no será posible construir una
casa allí en los próximos diez años no
hay nada no hay agua no hay electricidad
y el magma tardará años en enfriarse
al visitar el lugar de la erupción el
lunes el jefe del gobierno español dijo
que las autoridades están monitoreando
de cerca los incendios que pueden
originarse a partir de la lava ardiente
pedro sánchez volverá a la zona el
jueves junto con los reyes de felipe
sexto y letizia de que ahora mismo lo
más importante es garantizar la
seguridad la seguridad garantizar el
perímetro de la seguridad y por tanto
estamos todavía en la fase de la
erupción de la actividad del volcán por
favor extrememos la precaución no nos
aproximemos hasta su erupción el volcán
había estado inactivo durante 50 años
pero la última actividad podría durar
algún tiempo ya que otra reserva de
magma se ha ubicado a una profundidad de
casi 30 kilómetros bajo tierra